how's it going everybody it's Warren and
since spider-man far from home is
wrapping up phase 3 everybody is
starting to wonder what phase 4 looks
like a few weeks ago I did a video about
every movie that we knew was coming to
face 4 of the MCU
but now there's been a supposed leak of
the face for slate showing the movies
that we already knew were coming but
some new movies as well but all lining
up perfectly with how Marvel wants to
take the MCU in the future with a good
majority of the information on this leak
coming from or being confirmed by the
account called
Roger Wardell no one knows if that is
actually his true name but back in
December of 2018 before Avengers endgame
came out this person posted many
Avengers and game leaks that ended up
being 100% true including a lot of
characters returns Captain America
saying hail Hydra and the very first
thing this person posted back in
December was fat Thor so a very
legitimate source who has also been
talking about guardians of the galaxy 3
and Doctor Strange - so we're gonna go
ahead and break down this new Marvel
phase 4 slate leak but first to anyone
who is new to my channel I'm doing a
giveaway when I hit 400,000 subscribers
I will be picking three winners to
choose one item each from the Marvel
Legends series collection so make sure
you subscribe like the video and
comments that you can enter the giveaway
so the first movies that this leaked
states that are coming are Black Widow
the Eternals Black Panther 2 shang-chi
Doctor Strange 2 and guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 like I said we pretty much
knew these movies were already coming
but here's where it gets very
interesting the next movie that is said
to be in development already is Nova
now since Avengers endgame has come out
there have been many reports that Nova
is in fact in development and we've even
learned about a deleted scene between
fan OHS and Nova in Avengers infinity
war and/or endgame the writers revealed
that they originally had plans to show
thaäôs going to Zander and obtaining the
power stone which is where he would have
fought Nova so the fact that this states
that a Nova movie is in development is
right on track with everything that
we've heard so far this league then goes
on to talk about movies that are not yet
in development but are planned for phase
4 and the future of the MCU so even
though everybody is talking about phase
4 there might not be any more phases
Kevin Feige
has talked about getting rid of them but
there's been no confirmation yet so
until then we're just going to assume
like all these movies are going to be
coming out in phase four and phase five
so this leak goes on to say that there
are plans for Thor for this makes
perfect sense we know from Avengers
endgame that Thor story arc is not done
yet in fact the way they left it off
from Avengers in game made it seem like
there's a lot left at Thor story and we
know that Chris Hemsworth is not done
playing Thor yet so this makes perfect
sense the next movie it states is
ant-man 3 which also makes sense as well
a lot of people have speculated that
there would be another ant-man and why
wouldn't there be the movies have been
successful they haven't been huge like
all the other movies but they have been
very successful still and ant-man 3 will
probably be pretty important moving
forward and the MCU given the fact that
it's all about the quantum realm and
since the multiverse is being introduced
into the MCU the quantum realm will most
likely play a pretty important role in
traveling between the universes then we
have Captain Marvel 2 which obviously
this makes perfect sense they've already
set captain Marvel's going to be a big
character moving forward with the future
of the MCU but here's where this leak
gets really really interesting it says
that movies that Marvel has plans for
art the New Avengers The Young Avengers
and the Dark Avengers now the New
Avengers is a no brainer at some point
in time we're going to have new Avengers
and Avengers in games seem to set the
groundwork for the Young Avengers in
Avengers in game we saw Hawkeye training
his daughter Lyla with a bow and arrow
so she's set to take over his mantle we
saw Harley keiner at the genius boy from
Iron Man 3
we saw ant-man's daughter Cassie Lang
and not to mention at some point in time
Morgan Stark will most likely want to
take on her father's mantle so the
groundwork for the Young Avengers has
already been set in Avengers endgame but
the Dark Avengers is something that a
lot of people have begun to speculate
about recently especially if Norman
Osborn gets introduced into the MCU
which this leak does talk about later on
a leak then goes on to state that Falcon
and Winter Soldier
wandah vision Loki and Hawkeye are being
developed for Disney Plus but the
characters will still be featured in the
movies this has already been confirmed
as well by the Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige it then goes on to say that
the x-men and the Fantastic Four will
not appear until phase 5 which has
pretty much been confirmed by Kevin
Feige as well he said that we most
likely will not see the x-man or
Fantastic Four entered the MCU for at
least five years but then this leak goes
on to say that there
won't be another decade spanning
overarching storyline like the infinity
saga but there will be overarching mini
arcs spanning three to six films there
will be a more clear divide between
grounded MCU and cosmic MCU going
forward each having their own cast
specific tones and overarching
storylines we already knew that the
future of the MCU was going into the
cosmos specifically with guardians of
the galaxy and Captain Marvel and now
with a Nova movie in development but of
course you're still going to have events
happen on earth so it makes sense that
there would be some sort of a divide
between the two of them this makes sense
because if Captain Marvel and Thor were
fighting people galaxies away from Earth
they probably wouldn't interfere with
earth too much and wouldn't really
overlap with any story's going on on
earth so the fact that the cosmic MCU
and the grounded MCU are going to be
divided makes perfect sense we know
Chris Hemsworth has more movies left
doing guardians of the galaxy three and
four four and also Chris Pratt has
several movies left as well so there's
going to be plenty of cosmic MCU movies
the leak goes on to state that the main
antagonist for the grounded MCU is
supposed to be Norman Osborn provided
that Marvel and Sony renew their
contract this is something that
everybody is speculating about right now
especially because in the spider-man far
from home trailers and clips that we've
seen we've seen the older Avengers Tower
get bought reconstructed and is now
finished and everybody widely believes
now that it is the Oscorp building so
introducing Norman Osborn Oscorp and the
Green Goblin makes perfect sense moving
forward with the grounded MCU so that's
it for this leak on Marvel's face for an
upcoming future movies of the MCU keep
in mind that Kevin Feige said that
they're going to announce their plans
moving forward with the MCU after
spider-man far from home so spider-man
far from home comes out July 2nd and
then San Diego comic-con is July 18th
and Marvel is confirmed to be there this
year so this would be a perfect time to
introduce the phase 4 lineup in the
future movies of the MCU moving forward
of course that's just speculation but it
would be the perfect and ideal time for
Marvel to do that so we will officially
find out the slate of future Marvel
movies very soon again this leak has
merit to it but it is a leak so take it
with a grain of salt but let me know
what you think about this lineup are you
satisfied with it or would you like to
see different movies come to Marvel and
what are you looking forward to most
about the future of the MC
you let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again a reminder
about my giveaway when I hit 400,000
subscribers I will be picking three
winners and each will get to choose one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching its population and all it
took you said it cost you everything
while crying like a baby
now you're number